[Music]
I'm so delighted to be able to announce
our next speaker Chris Koya Adam many of
you all know Chris from around on the on
the Internet he's been I don't want to
call him old but he's been around there
for a while sorry Christopher
he was absolutely behind so many of the
resources that have taught me so much
throughout my web development career you
know CSS tricks has become this
canonical reference for all kinds of
content all kinds of things to do with
web development
I'm always baffled at how quickly after
something new comes along Chris is able
to grasp it see its importance learn
about it produce content that is just so
valuable for everyone and that has
incredible longevity and just kind of
sticks around so it's kind of staggering
to see Chris is going to come and talk
to us now about you know the power of
the all-powerful front-end developer and
that makes me happy because that's
that's my background so please make him
very very welcome is Chris Koya ever
yeah flashlight mmm all-powerful friend
of allure I've been a friend of
developer for a long time it's very near
and dear to my heart and it's so cool
what's happening and that front-end
developers aren't just getting so much
more powerful in what we can do and this
with this we're going to talk about for
half an hour it's gonna be awesome I'm I
work at code pen and do CSS tricks and
chop talk show as well why does it say
bookmark this page isn't that weird
you can see that whatever that's
annoying enough to fix with
there it goes you want to read my email
- there's something cool so like before
any of the stuff that we're gonna talk
about today friend developers have
already been super powerful we always
had like a super important role and that
can and the construction of web sites
you know like Ok Go buddy yeah all of
you acts as important of UX is it's like
the most important thing we can possibly
deal with when making a website what is
it like for the users to use the
front-end developer crafts all of it you
know like it's in on totally in our
hands what the experience of using a
website is like performance that's on
front-end developers primarily a big
chunk of perf is a front-end development
situation all of accessible and people
can yeah you can have specialists like
think about UX and wireframes stuff and
do research but the put the putting it
into a website it's all friend
developers just like accessibility
that's in front-end developers hands the
execution of a design and integrating
the animations and interactions and all
that stuff that's all front-end
development work
that's incredible we have so much work
to do already front-end developers that
you can make a sweet career out of it
and lots of people are doing it and I
love it I've done it and I just think
wow what a cool job the best job in the
world being a front-end developer and
there's a certain skill set that comes
along with the job certainly those
things it's generally like some of those
things you specialize in some of them
whatever you add a few things to that
party but there is some kind of like
roadblock eventually that's the point
you're a front-end developer which means
that you don't have some other skills
probably so there's some kind of like
roadblock to your front-end development
skills we're like okay my skillset has
expired and now I need somebody else to
help me and this talk is kind of about
like where is that and where is it
changing and I'm kind of interested in
just kicking it down I mean like I don't
I don't need anybody's help anymore I
can do everything which I love so
there's some kind of like there's a when
does it stop
generally it stops when you need like
some some hardcore back-end help or like
server ops kind of stuff at least that's
been the case for me so if you don't
need any servers you know well I don't
know why that this word hasn't come up
as much at this conference so I feel
like it's just as buzzword E as Jam
stack
is to some degree so I'm gonna say it a
whole bunch just unapologetically and
I'm not even gonna give some caveat
that's like well they're still servers
involved boo-boo no I'm gonna do it I
made a website called the power of
server list dot info that it's just a
bunch of links and stuff so don't worry
about like jotting down links and stuff
we talked about some service it's up on
this microsite that's kind of related to
this talk so let's look at one of the
major ingredients of I'd say Jam stack
but definitely observer list which is
this whole idea of cloud functions there
so cool
it's some JavaScript and you put it on a
server but not your server somebody
else's server which is great and it's
probably node you know it doesn't have
to be but it probably is especially for
the people in this room and then you got
a website and all you need to know is
that you execute that code by hitting a
URL of some kind you hit the URL the
code runs that's all that a cloud
function is it's sounds boring but it's
cool why would you ever do that well
let's not be abstract about it let's
talk about real reasons why you'd do it
let's say your boss is like ok we work
at we work at food recipes or sad-ass
you work on a recipe site and you're
tasked with oh we need to like have an
input field and you type in your phone
number and you get the recipe on your
phone it's like a feature that you're
tasked with building so if you're like a
front-end developer you're like I got
this I can do they design it I can do
the UX for it I can build the form I can
think about the states I can do all this
work but at some point my friend and
develop I'm done and I gotta kick it
over the fence to somebody who can let
go the last mile and make it do the
actual thing I'm sending a text message
that's the roadblock that we're gonna
kick over we're gonna be like ok Twilio
that's the app that you use to send text
messages cool got it that's the thing
I'm a little afraid of like you don't
know I don't know how to do that it
seems like back-end nerd stuff this is
where my front-end skills expire and
somebody else comes to help me like I
said this is what we're gonna we're
gonna scratch out so how do we do it
well it's not because Twilio announced
that they have client side only api's
and we can just do it in the browser
they don't have that they don't have
that on purpose because you need API
keys to deal with your Twilio account
because if you're the API keys are the
keys to the kingdom if some bad person
slides in here and steals your API keys
for Twilio they're gonna
all of Texas to vote for Ted Cruz that's
something that you don't want something
bad is going to happen to you if they
get your API keys that's why you need to
protect them behind server-side code
that's a traditional use case of why you
need a server I need to protect my API
keys you just have to do that you can't
protect them client-side I need a server
to do this in some way it's not the case
for all api's flickers got an API you
can use it to search first Church for
pictures you don't need any API keys you
don't need a server for this this is all
happening client-side this also makes
you powerful as a front-end developer
but it's not gonna help us in the Twilio
situation so we're gonna use a server
but not really we're gonna use somebody
else's server and we're gonna do it this
way so that's our little clout what a
cloud function is diagram we're gonna
write our little JavaScript code we're
gonna put it on somebody else's server
and we're gonna communicate with that
via URLs the web's finest feature so if
we're gonna run some JavaScript code and
we need to put it on a server somewhere
or whatever why can't we just use the
one that's already powering our recipe
website like why not because this is why
now because our server doesn't run
anything in the background so we maybe
could if it was like an old-school
server that we don't have but now we Jam
stacking baby our server don't have node
on it on purpose
let's say our recipe website is running
on github pages or code pen projects or
obviously melih Phi's the choice here or
I'm gonna dump all that crap in an s3
bucket
guess which back-end languages none of
those things have all of them that was
complicated
none of those run any back-end languages
you know like github pages will not run
your Python script nullify will not run
your PHP function code pen projects will
not run your node JavaScript yet so but
why would you choose those things
because it's super cheap it's super fast
its CDN edge don't we call it a CDN edge
no I don't know why there's youth
they're super secure there's no database
to break into there's no file
permissions to set that you get a HTM
the HTTP that you don't have to frickin
deal with it's such a pain in yeah
they're just very front-end developer
friendly places to put your code it's a
fundamental kind of concept of this Jam
stack stuff that's where our recipe
website lives so that's why we don't
have a place to run our little function
to talk to Twilio
so let's server list up serverless it up
this website which I have no affiliation
with or anything it's just it helps me
understand what a cloud function is so
maybe this will be useful to you too
it's called web tasks dot IO it's a
little bit like code pen in that it's an
editor in the browser so I can open up
web tasks and I that can actually edit
that code and I can make a function so
here's just a function that takes some
data and when it's done doing whatever
it's gonna do it calls a callback and
returns that data what's cool about web
paths I can test it right in there I can
press that Run button and I'll run that
function so here I'm gonna post I'm
gonna fake post to this piece of code
and I'm gonna pass it some form data foo
bar or whatever hit the Run button and I
can see that it returns
I can even console dot log stuff in
there and it returns a little piece of
JSON for me to use cool so now I have
this like piece of node that I'm
executing now so but that node is
useless the node code I want is I'm
going to just go copy and paste some
crap out of the Twilio Docs because
that's how I need to send a text message
they'll have an NPM Lib that you can
just grab they'll have documentation
that's just like I don't know fill in
the blanks you know that it's their job
to make this easy for you to use so here
I've done it I just went to Coolio I'm
importing Twilio from Julia I don't even
know what that Lib does but I'm just
following the docs you know there's some
API key stuff in there and I'm just
gonna that's their documentation for how
to send a text message and then web test
has a place to keep your secrets if you
want to so
the world kind of can't see them but
crucially they give you a URL to hit it
that they've give you that now I have a
URL to run my function which is great
now I can use it and this is cool
old-school web I can use this function
with not no client-side JavaScript at
all we can just have a forum I'm gonna
post to that URL that they just gave me
and I'm gonna ask her a phone number to
send it to and just pass it some value
to send or whatever and it has a submit
button and that's it so I can run that
on codepen it's just a it's that's it
there's no CSS or JavaScript involved
here at all I just type in my own phone
number there and never call me and I'm
just having it barf out so but I mean
you know I'm in Mac OS so I have my
iMessage set up or whatever and it's
working it's hitting Twilio with that
data and it's sending me a text message
I put that together and I have no
business doing that which is great and
so yeah and you don't even have to have
it spit out crap I could have told that
node function to redirect to some
success page or something like that it's
probably more likely though that you'd
have an event listener on your form and
you whatever post to the to the URL that
I said and you send it some data and
then wait for the response and do fancy
animations on your page or whatever
that's probably a more likely scenario
but it's kind of cool that you can do it
with progressive enhancement too and
this is what I did you know I made a
dumb little recipe website where you can
type in the phone number and you get
these lovely little recipe for for
oatmeal cookies so that's totally part
of Jam stack and server lists but this
is this can get harder and easier than
that here's an example of getting a lot
easier let's say you need a form on your
website that's something else a contact
form or something I need back-end code
to be able to deal with that so what do
you used or we're gonna have to bright a
cloud function and protect our API keys
and blah blah sure you could do it like
that
but you don't have to because this is a
super old need on the web like people
have needed to put forms on websites and
there's been startups to help them do
that forever
so there's Google Forms or whatever and
whoo flu and type form and formstack and
jawed form there's a million apps to do
this I think you know as old as V seen
this is a part of Jam sack - if you ask
me this means somebody else deal with my
forms a let somebody else's servers and
stuff that specialize in that be part of
this website and I don't need any
back-end languages or anything else you
know I think that's part of this story
as well I can take a woofer form and
have it work right on code pad it's just
copy and paste code and that's a fully
functional payment enabled form that I
could host anywhere but there's a you
know more a little bit more Jam stachy
maybe is this idea that you can just
bring your own HTML form and then just
point the action attribute at one of
these other services like a new breed of
form processors you just pass it that
and that's how form carry works and page
clip and nullify forms of course and
basin you know there's all these these
new form processors that help you deal
with forms as well and these exist
because this is a big deal which is cool
so don't don't worry about any of those
services that's why this website the
power of server let's not info exists so
that all it rounds up all these services
there's a million of them so let's say
you need to take some money for your
fing ecommerce odd I don't know I give
up I'm just gonna use Shopify or Magento
or I don't know that the kids these days
know about Magento still but you don't
really have to - like how would you do
Jam stachy ecommerce how does that work
well there's a million ways to cut it
but the easiest way in the universe is
just to use a Buy Now button
I have little scarfs oh well here's all
the players right we know them they
they're literally all here in San
Francisco
PayPal I sell scarfs I'm gonna put a
frickin PayPal button on the thing when
they click it they go to PayPal they pay
for the thing they come back to my scarf
website and and then PayPal tells me
about it so then I ship them the scarf
or whatever that's Jam stacking that's I
don't need any back-end languages to do
this I'm totally enabled as a front-end
developer to have e-commerce on my
website the oldest way in the book or
you can get all fancy with it this is a
Sarah Dresner demo where she you know
who you know works for Microsoft and on
Azure and and it's on the view core team
this is a view demo where it's all fancy
it's got filtering and there's a cart
and you know she made up this whole
e-commerce demo but it also has a
payment form on it so look as she
filters and it's all modern and fancy
and then you go to the cart and the kart
has items in it but you can actually
check out and this isn't just totally
faked she integrated this with stripe so
this is just using the fake stripe
credit card number but this would
actually work in process code it's this
thing else all the proper code is there
to do it you pay with the credit card
and stripe is communicated with the card
is actually processed and it's it's
doing all that kind of real ecommerce
work but there's no server here this is
still all Jam stachy in the way that it
works is that the backend is or the
front as view the processing is stripe
but the way that those two mix because
of course stripe has API keys that you
need to protect you better help protect
your stripe API keys they're
communicated with cloud functions in
this case on Azure so stripe again they
want to help you do this API Docs for
stripe are incredible you know but it's
but it's you know so you need to put it
somewhere so in this case she's using
Azure and in you the azure has an
interface I think this is probably an
old ish screenshot I think it's been
redesigned a little bit but what's kind
of cool about this is that in this case
you see how it's all kind of grayed out
Sarah put these in a github repo so her
fun her cloud functions are part of like
the rest of her codebase it's just she's
shipping them up to Azure here too so
you don't have to use an online editor
for your cloud functions can live in
your repo along with all the rest of
your code cool kind of cool just because
we're talking about payments I think
this is worth knowing about that
browsers have this new
the web payment API and the whole point
of it isn't to like they're not actually
processing payments for you what
browsers are trying to give you here is
free ui/ux
for checking out from pages like they'll
be your shopping cart and your address
collector and credit card information
acceptor it's this piece that they're
trying to give you and that's so cool
because it's just it's consistent across
sites then and they'll you know the
people have their saved addresses and
saved credit cards and stuff it's but
it's just the ui/ux you still need to
bring your own payment processing so you
still need stuff like you know server
less functions to process your stripe
calls and all that kind of stuff but
it's worth knowing about it I think
that's some future web stuff that works
nicely in a gem stack situation so
here's another one let's say you need
comment threads this might be a moment
worried like yeah gem stacks cool but I
need I literally need comments on my
website so what am I going to do about
that I'm just gonna give up and use
WordPress or something but no but
comments are great structured data
they're great for databases there's no
reason to forsake databases because
they're kind of perfect for stuff like
this you need their name and their what
piece of what article that comment was
associated with and the value of the
comment and when it happened and whether
it's approved or not and it's great
structured data so sure you could just
reach for WordPress but let's assume
that you're gonna use a static site
generator instead so that X site
generators are so hot I'm gonna use
middleman or whenever there's a bunch of
them they're all great there's Hugo and
Gatsby's the cool one right and there's
hexo and metal Smith and jekyll and
middleman and eleventy is the new hot
one isn't it so but you but you don't
you know they're they don't have like
comment threads aren't like a native
feature of any of these things so in the
way that they generally work is you know
there's the content lives in your repo
it's a big pile of markdown files
actually at an interesting conversation
last night where it's not necessarily
that it's just anything that returns a
promise kind of thing it was so
interesting conversation but because so
it wouldn't necessarily need to be a
bunch of markdown files it could hit
your content full API or something but
still statically generate total aside
there but it smashes all that together
with some templates and it makes like a
directory that's a website like a bunch
of files that you could put in
where you put it in your s3 bucket or
let know if I run it for you or whatever
they all work the same way but none of
them really have comments as a feature
so what are we to do well we don't
really have a database at our command so
let's just put discus on it which is
fine and it solves you know that comes
with its own can of worms but that's
been like solving that problem for us
forever and as such is kind of part of
the the gem stack universe in a way but
like let's really nerd this one up like
let's go full-bore nerd on the comment
thread thing let's want to roll our own
system so we're gonna use Hugo because
Hugo's cool right
that's our static site generator we and
we're gonna put a comment form on it
where we collect their name and their
email and what comment and when you
click the button it's gonna turn into a
piece of like structured data we'll just
format it as Jason and we'll throw it up
and firebase is great for that it's
basically Jason base can just throw our
you know I know there's more to it than
this I'm being a bit on purpose but
we'll keep that data in firebase well it
could be spam it could be garbage so
we're gonna have a when that happens and
of course we'll do this through a cloud
function you know the ssin will also hit
slack and slack will have a channel and
I'll say do I approve or disapprove this
message and if you say a proof if you
say disapprove it maybe just does
nothing but if it hits approve then
maybe that cloud function then can hit
nullify and trigger a build that'd be
kind of cool and during that build will
have Hugo go get all approved comments
from that post and do it in the build
process so now we have a comment thread
the data is stored in a database kind of
where it's nice to keep things like
comments but we can still statically
generate our site like that's a kind of
flow that is just cool and gem stocky
and server Lisi and just kind of sweet
and a little bit like that stir things
around but it's kind of sweet
that's Phil's version Phil's is cool
Phil Phil yes it uses like the nullify
like kind of you know when you use
nullify forms it just uses nullify as a
database kind of kind of cool so what
about what about real-life cloud
functions like these were all little
hobby
kind of things but it clearly sites use
them all the time code pen uses the crap
out of cloud functions here's one of the
things we use cloud functions for you
can write in a bunch of different
preprocessor languages on code like your
HTML you can write it or any of these
other languages your CSS you can write
in popular CSS preprocessor languages
JavaScript - we will process for you in
a number of different ways we could and
we have we are connected this many times
throughout the life of code pen but
we've really settled on cloud functions
as a way to do this because it's sweet
so all these languages are written in
node which is a thing that lambda which
is another cloud services provider can
run so we have little cloud functions
whose whole job on earth is to take some
less CSS and turn it into CSS and return
it that's its own that's all it does in
the world it's it's own little job and
then there's a couple other languages
out there that you know sass there's
dart SAS these days which you haven't
Explorer but there's some other
languages that just don't run in a
language that cloud functions can
generally run for whatever reason cloud
functions don't love ruby who knows but
like in the world of code pen the ones
that are on the left side of this screen
are certainly uh kind of happier you
know that they're cheaper they're easier
to secure they're easier to scale they
don't break that often it's not like the
stuff on the right is untenable like we
can manage it that we're that's the
business that we're in but certainly if
you can run it as a cloud function off
your life just gets so much easier and
better and less expensive and stuff it's
great all right let's do another one
just because we can let's say you need
to be able to build a like a CR around
like your boss is like hey bro can you
build me like an app to like track our
customers and like if they got a gift
box or not for Christmas and you'd be
like yes boss I can
like no no like an app you know and
you're like yes I can build you that app
you know but anyways like no like let's
do it for real like we're get we got to
build a crud app you know create read
update delete like every app that most
of us write we all write crud apps all
day long we're gonna need some
structured data for our customers and
whether they got a gift box or not fine
where should we put that it'd be kind of
rad to use air table I don't know if any
of you have seen this it's a great
little app it's spreadsheet like base
they have a great UI
which is just cool on its own but they
have Jason api's for all that data so if
we run it it's a cheap easy solution
like that we're gonna make a little crud
app using air table it's great for that
but air table also has API keys that you
probably don't want to put in your
client-side JavaScript you can but not
great you know this is like your private
data air table has also great API so
they run node you can make a wet a cloud
function that does all the crud stuff
for air table and pull and push data
like oh they got their gift box or
whatever that's a perfect use case for
cloud functions this is another Sarah
Dresner demo where she made her and her
team speak at all these events so she
made this crazy WebGL globe of where
they're speaking and when and all this
stuff but it you can run this anywhere
you could run this on a gem stack thing
because the way that she did it was
basically built a little crud at the the
data store in this case is just a JSON
file but she made a little UI for adding
and updating stuff that run cloud
functions in Azure in this case and then
it's a view app again on the front-end
let's say you want to build a blog like
is is is do you have to run a static
site generator on gemspec to have a blog
or is there other ways to do it of
course there's other ways to do it
it's just structured data and this is a
you know this worth googling we won't
get into a whole bunch but kit kit
Hodgdon made this for us on code pen
which is a way to spin up a blog and
totally server Leslie so you can run it
on code pen which has no database or
back-end functions or back in languages
remember but here is like Monica was
talking about here's how easy firebase
off is it's like two lines of code
you're like oh cool now I have login for
my app great and now that I'm logged in
and authenticated I can write posts and
I'm writing a post and it's gonna turn
that data into Jason send it up to fire
base and now I have a new blog and it
persists in the cloud right you refresh
this page that blog post that I just
authored will be there so a serverless
blog how cool is that and did it all on
code pen this got me empowered to I'm
like I'm gonna make a food log I could
download one of them 2 billion of them
on my phone or whatever but I'll write
one myself just to see if I can do it so
I use firebase I have off now I type in
what food I ate what calories and it
saves it to firebase and it stores it by
date and adds up the calories for me and
all that stuff that's so empowering
that is me kicking down the door of what
I'm able to do as a front-end developer
and it's badass I think anyway I just
called myself a badass which is not the
case so you want to send notifications
for your app we already talked about
sending SMS but what if you are running
a bug tracker and it needs to send a
slack notice or an email notice or
whatever it's the same kind of thing you
build cloud functions that do that job
that's what this world is all about
these days you can make this work that
roadblock can be gone for you how to
slack do it slack wants to you wants you
to hit at URL to you want to send a
message to a slack channel they're just
like here's the URL hit it with your
data and we'll do that for you so you'd
write a cloud function that hit their
URL and does the job you know we're not
looking at the code here we're talking
about empowerment what you can do
there's sending email there's things
like mail gun and spark post and send
grid they're just api's for sending
emails what do you think we're gonna do
we're gonna write a they're gonna give
us some node code we're gonna put it in
a cloud function and now we have a URL
that we can post to that will send an
email so now we have this bug tracker
app that we're going with so anyway we
talked about web toss that was a really
easy way to get started with them and
feel out what they are we looked as
yours got cloud functions firebase will
run on Google cloud functions AWS lamda
is probably the biggest provider of them
and nullifies got them of course - which
is really rad because it's so easy I'm
not laughing you just put your function
dot J s in a folder called functions
kick it to your nullify and now at your
website like it just makes a relative
you are
that you can execute that function
through lambda it's like the easiest way
ever to get started with cloud functions
they really did a good job with that
which is cool so it's another way to get
started with with cloud functions how
much is this stuff gonna cost I think
this is funny so for like a hundred
thousand tile if we hit our cloud
function to send an email a hundred
thousand times and it ran for half a
second each time which is way longer
than it'll take to run and we use this
512 megabytes of RAM which is way more
than it'll ever need we're looking at
like 50 cents so pretty affordable I'd
say in the terms of this kind of stuff
it's not always the right answer but for
this kind of stuff it's pretty
no-brainer II it reminds do you all
watch Kelton catch fire if you didn't
you should go home tonight and watch all
of it because it's the best show ever
but in like season four they they kind
of invent this concept in the 80s
they're like these big computers are
just sitting around doing nothing at
night we should have them run it will
sell the time the unused computer time
which is kind of a cloud functions are I
think you know AWS has all these servers
sitting around that are pre bought and
not doing anything they're like well
third there are doing something they're
executing my cloud functions when I need
them anyway so look at look at now we're
little architects we have this bug
tracker app or whatever that sensed SMS
messages and it sends emails and it
sends slack messages and we've written
cloud functions for each one of those
things oh we found this cool abstraction
mailer so instead of using spark posts
api's directly will use this abstraction
that way if we need to change providers
we can we're like oh yeah I'm totally
gonna use that so now my mailer function
isn't tied to spark post but it's kind
of an abstraction cool and then like I
don't know it's weird to have our
clients be in charge of calling all
these api's directly why don't we write
a cloud function that's like just a
notifier and we send say okay notifier i
want you to send an SMS to this location
and so it can kind of be like a little
router for all these things just to give
ourselves a little bit of abstraction in
here and all of a sudden we're thinking
we're like freaking architects all the
sudden we haven't learned anything
really but we
all of a sudden were like back-end
developers to you know which is great so
we got to close this thing down half an
hour it's not out of breath you know
serverless
it's this ingredient list it's not like
if you go serverless or you go gem stock
you have to do all of it but it can do
all kinds of interesting things and it's
incremental adoption for days you can
just ooh that looks nice I'll have one
of these and one of these you know it's
not just for hobbyist things it's not
just for crazy enterprise sites it's for
everybody it's amazing how I've seen the
usage of this serverless jams tech stuff
all across it's not for it's not
prescriptive in any type of website you
know there's very clearly people doing
gem stock for publishing of like lots of
content blog type stuff publication type
stuff and clearly as for web apps
whatever those things are people are
using the crap out of that stuff so it's
it's just everybody's using it it in
some way the perf story is so great for
it especially on something like metal
afire your whole site like the document
will come back like that and then the
rest of it is like for you to screw up I
know the security so great you know I
let's one of the things I totally love
about Jam stock is it's not like oh my
god how am I gonna secure this database
what file permissions should these PHP
files be like what way what where our
bad guys knocking on the door of this
website that I don't know about I hate
that stuff I don't want that to be my
job my job has already gotten bigger as
a front-end developer and dealing with
anything security related just isn't my
favorite thing to do so it's so nice
that I can feel powerful and not worry
about it so the kind of the point of
this isn't that everything that we've
talked about this conference is the best
thing in the entire universe and you
should do all of it immediately it's
about your brain knowing what's up and
what's out there and being able to pick
from that ingredients list when you can
it's great your brain is now smarter
that's the dumb little website I made
the power of server list info I have the
Twitter handle CSS now how cool is that
right
anyway that's that's my whole talk
thanks everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you